all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel today
i'm gonna do morning coffee thought but
it's not the morning i don't have coffee
or even any beverage today
but i just want to make a video so let's
talk before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos and
leave a comment let me know what you
want to hear me talk about next time
so today
i'm going gonna talk about a couple
experiences i've had
the first off everyone's asking me what
my next show will be and the answer is i
don't know
we had some issues with the wi-fi we
just got the the wi-fi working today
and i hope to get it up
the the equipment and everything running
by tomorrow
my producer's coming tonight hopefully
we can do a show tomorrow
but nothing's promised and there always
seems to be something that goes wrong so
i feel like saturday will be the very
latest
the very little but i don't even want to
prom i don't even want to promise that
anyways um on top of that i have another
another request so
my request
you won't believe
the video i saw the the conspiracy
theory i saw on me
i was i was shook shook okay
they were saying i was part of the deep
state and i was like
first of all i don't even truly
understand what the deep state is but
apparently it's like the most powerful
people like behind the scenes they've
run everything i'm like
oh my god you guys think i could be one
of the most powerful people in the world
cool
i was
i was pumped i was like
yeah
but anyways
so they thought this because for two
reasons this is the funniest thing
one is because i have a rich dad you
guys know this i didn't hide this that
was like my first youtube video it was a
house tour
second thing
is
oh my gosh
i i worked for a democrat in college and
i know you're thinking why would you
work for democrat ah
shock and awe but like in college i
don't really care i was just looking for
an internship
and the funniest thing about this
internship is i'm pretty sure maybe on
my linkedin where they found it or my
resume whatever it was i
put that it was for three months i put
three months
was how long i worked there but in all
honesty i think i worked there maybe
three weeks
um
and
sorry there's like a construction worker
across and i'm like making it he's like
what are you doing okay okay
sir
anyways um anyways
because it was an unpaid internship and
i was like this is stupid so i was it
was honestly just close to my school
but yeah they gathered deep state from
that that was kind of funny
now the second thing people wanted to
hear about my first festival so
i've okay
sorted my first festival i went to
country thunder when i was 16 with my
mother
you could say
granted i went with friends and my
mother but you you could argue you could
argue that it wasn't my first festival
but
this is like my first real one as an
adult so
what happened
at my first festival so
i
was shocked i went there to do
interviews okay interview people and let
me tell you
next time i'm gonna go for like 10 hours
straight because
i don't know i just like
i got so many crazy people and so many
different like types of interviews and
like like i talked to a religious person
with a sign i talked to some girl that
had like crazy plastic surgery i talked
to so many people and i was like i could
only do this at like a festival so but
at the end i told my cameraman the
festival ended at eight it was like
carnival here which is like insane and
i was like at seven i was like go home
i'm gonna see if i can like enjoy the
festival see if i like it
and every time i ask someone this
question like what would you do at a
festival all day
and
the answer here is it's just vibes just
vibe and i'm like i don't drink
so i'm just like
you just what do you mean just vibe
like what does that mean so you're gonna
and so there would be like a a dj guy
and then the dj guy would be doing music
but i'm like i could listen to this
music at home what is what why
and then everyone's just standing there
and then
all of a sudden you'll be walking and a
whole crowd will come by and you'll be
like like so close to people that it's
like
and
sorry the construction worker is looking
at me like what are you doing and
and i'm like
first of all first of all i don't like
being by this many people second of all
what is just vibing if just vibing is
drinking listening to music i could
listen to at home
and
and
wearing nothing because everyone there
was wearing damn near nothing i swear to
god i was i've seen so much ass and then
people would bring their children why
are your kids at a festival where
people's asses are out like don't you
believe in preserving the innocence of
children i do i do anyways
so i want to know from the people what
the hell is just vibing
i'm a people person i like being around
people but what i don't like being
around is people that are so close to me
and then
the guys will just try to grab you to
dance with you and i'm like ah
no no no no
i just met you
i just met you
and this was only in an hour i'm like i
can't even do that i don't even think it
was a full hour i can't even imagine
doing this eight hours straight
just vibes
just about what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
is vibes
fives
anyways um i have to go to volleyball
after this but
i'm not sure i'm the festival type
i can't imagine doing that for eight
hours
i saw people puke
a lot of angry drunks a lot of happy
drunks
but yeah not my thing not my thing
anyways let me know in the comments what
you guys think
what other events in england should i go
to because i'd like to go to more for
interviews for interviews not not to
vibes not just vibes
anyways let me know comment below like
the video love you bye